gaze into the kimi o looking forward now
yeah so would like 35 days it is oh my
god five days in and you've got 54 days
left ah that's nerve-racking it is very
nerve-wracking but we're going to work
as hard as we can you know reach the
public with this project as best as we
can we're gonna tweet it and until my
fingers fall off I'm going to email
isn't it down emerica haven't slept in
we haven't slept with just an online
they all night just sending it to people
trying to reach reach reach a lot of
people out there something to try to
help us support this project we're
getting very good responses a lot of
people really like the project and
really like the videos and uh they
they're inspired by a to the thing is
that I learnt to know people are they
gravitate to the child abduction human
trafficking in this country too so
they're like I didn't know that and I
have a supplementary video that gives a
lot of statistics about those subjects
and when people see that again I'm
getting a lot of emails and tweets back
about I didn't know that it was really
happening here and then that just gives
me more and more fuel and lets me know
that this point you know film needs to
be made so that people can be more aware
of it is anybody resonating with the
characters trying to change the course
that they were once on and
or is that not totally review not
totally revealed that's the to me I
think that's more than intricacies of
the story and for me to something up the
the real cause for me though it's a
great story but the real cause to me is
the child abduction human trafficking
you know in the country I hope people
are really aware that and and uh you
know become aware that that is something
that's happening here and you know and
you know I hope that inspires people to
really get behind the cause but uh the
Cape start has been going really good on
we've got a long way to go but you know
we're still going to keep pushing it and
getting it out there and we hope people
you know help us get this film made and
so what are the ground rules you have
like do you have a daily checklist of
what you do or just you just know every
day's go hit the ground running to me
and him something like some people have
like a team of like 20 people before the
catch start it just me and him so I got
the the morning routine go online and he
also does the same thing so we do it in
the morning and a nice little blueberry
sleep we honor all the time we take like
bracer and sometimes you get
discouraged why I just sending like a
thousand email I mean it's still not
moving you know me and then uh oh yeah
somebody play them okay good let's keep
going this TV luck it doesn't take much
to keep us going and all I need is a
good to hear you mate we date I'm so boy
I'm not gonna quit if you retweet me
I'll take the little things for now but
yeah we work in shifts and you know is
we take our breaks you know you know cuz
you put in hours doing that you get kind
of loopy looking at the screen so much
today you know take a break and you know
get a cup of coffee go at it again you
know in the end is you know it's just
trying to reach as many people you know
as we can I think we have to get a lot
of people let me be like a step that
like like the page or they just send us
a message we like we like the project
instead of their own place but we get a
lot of in-depth that like the project
and stuff like that so we reach you some
of them
we didn't good so far the time frame to
Leon five days so we're doing good so
far so what are some of the highs and
some of the loans what like what things
are the ones where you go hmm and then
takes you back up again size of tweets
okay ah it's just filmmaking in general
or the Kickstarter compulsion for the
kicks to pass out going so yeah it's
literally like luckily it's it would
never had a point where we're both down
yeah yo yo yo call me five four in the
morning you you go and I'll call them
again L you go call them with quality
light and maybe like two three I we call
each other I was I'll definitely say the
low for me is if you get back somebody
like uh you know you get some negatives
every once in a while like oh you know I
don't know you so don't send me tweets
and stuff like that you get you get
stuff like that but they're not you know
you hit a couple people later and
somebody retweets me and I'm saying
thank you Anna and that's enough for me
to keep going because not everybody
shares the same mentality and you know
it I just feed off of that you know
you're gonna have negativity and things
like that but you you have to again here
comes the thick skin you just let it
roll off and you keep on going you know
so you're your own support system yeah
yeah yeah yeah absolutely absolutely and
it works cuz we're both stubborn
extremely slow and so quick we're gonna
find some way to get to it yeah like my
mom said somebody blocks you try to
break the dog go through it so that's
how we that's how we doing yeah
you